They have their own story.
Some of them have been there so much
longer than we have been there
and will be there...
outlive all of us.
You lose that sense of time
and you're suddenly surrounded
by all these new smells
and these sounds of the birds
and the sounds of those branches
when they creak.
It just is like a whole amazing
thing for the senses.
That's what I'm trying.
I'm trying to get that feeling of...
the mystery of it.
Whenever I walk into
a woods, I always feel
that I'm entering into a different
pattern of time or something.
the way light is chopped up
by the leaves.
It feels like the moment itself
is chopped up a little bit
and lots of different moments
are almost held within the envelope
of that little forest
in quite a magical way.
It's actually quite hard to envisage
an environment without trees
and their habitats and what they mean
and how they behave.
It's a rich, creative world
and I can't think that anybody's life
is worse off for having trees in it.
Part of improving it for wildlife
is increased number of trees.
Because trees do quite useful things,
don't they?
Anyone got any ideas what trees do?
We as Muslims
believe we are custodians,
caretakers of the Earth.
So we're hoping that
by planting a tree,
we will benefit the Earth and it will
preserve it for future generations.
If a Muslim plants a tree,
and a bird, an animal or a child
benefits from it then it will be
classed as a charitable act.
And it's an act that doesn't stop -
it can carry on
even till the hereafter.
I suppose I connect trees
with memory really, and with time.
And maybe even learning about time.
A is for Apple. A is for Acorn.
Maybe there's some dim
connection in my head
between trees and alphabets
and books and learning.
I'm particularly interested
in the relationship
between people and trees.
I know probably a few hundred
of the trees in this plantation
personally.
I revisit the same tree and think,
"How are you today?
Are you springtime yet?
I want to know when the tree first
produces its first flowers.
It's like a farmer having lambs.
It's that same thrill
of seeing new life isn't it?
I have to try and get this right
'cause it's a really good quote
about nature.
"Still, nature is the
fountain's head,
the source from whence
all must originally spring
and should an artist continue his
practice without referring to nature
he must soon form a manner."
And that's what I was finding
was happening with my work.
I was like, "Actually my work is
becoming incredibly mannered."
So I went into
the middle of the rainforest
and did a residency in the jungle.
And didn't intend on it
becoming the whole
rest of my practice...
well not forever, but up until now.
And just fell in love
with these landscapes.
And I came home
and after being in this place
where my eyes were completely opened
to the twists of the branches
and the curls and the leaves,
and when I was looking
at my own landscape
and all these woodlands around me,
it was like I was looking at them
for the first time.
And so it continued this
inspiration that I had to paint them.
"It was Monday, Bank Holiday,
near the end of May,
rough middle of the day,
year and of the country
if the country is England.
Oak apple or oak and nettle day,
axis of my year
thinly plotted as my tree -
the far end of our thinning garden,
in a border shaped to waver
like a child's drawing of sea.
Its clock-handed Y
where the trunk parted ways,
a first rung, that even just turned
seven I step onto,
into the above,
this wobbly earth above earth.
Wordlessly I knew then,
I'd later be gone,
like possibly my tree has,
from that border,
and my attention divided
thinly as the light,
or is that time, through the
green-grey space I was sitting in
as I reached up for a branch,
or is it balance, or vantage?
On this tentative level. A story."
How did it feel to plant a tree?
Something to be proud of, yeah.
Cool.